we begin this half-hour with a routine
maintenance mission aboard the
International Space Station in made
history high above the earth NASA
astronauts Christina cook and Jessica
Muir completed the first all-female
spacewalk while the eyes of the world
were watching the mission went off
without a hitch
Jessica Christine we are so proud of you
you're going to do great today we'll be
waiting for you here in a couple hours
when you get home Judy thank you so much
my pleasure working with you this
morning it began at 7:30 8:00 Eastern
Time when Christina cook and Jessica Mir
first stepped into outer space tethered
to the space station by all two thin
cords and began their mission to replace
a faulty power control the box is just
here right ok 7 hours and 17 minutes
later the job was complete and they
closed the hatch behind them the repair
job mark cook's fourth spacewalk in
mears first but it's the first time two
women have ever ventured out of a
spacecraft as a team station this is
President Donald Trump do you hear me
that's great and president Trump
congratulated them while the two were
still at work in a video call from the
White House thanking them for their
bravery and service the first woman to
ever walk in space was Russian cosmonaut
vet lana Savitz kaya the first american
kathy sullivan followed a year later but
plans for an all-women's walk earlier
this year had to be scuttled when NASA
realized the space station lacked a
second properly fitting suit it was an
embarrassing oversight that was not
overlooked by Saturday Night Live back
here on earth this has got to be
disappointed NASA's next milestone could
come in 2024 when the agency plans a
return trip to the moon very possibly
with a woman taking that small step and
giant leap onto the lunar
surface one good indication the mission
is named Artemis after the twin sister
of the Greek god Apollo
I love how a routine mission is seven
hours seven hours in 17 minutes
I don't have the attention span for that
I'm not gonna lie congratulations today
no great step forward